okay let's continue
short simple games thus far today 1850
ladies and gentlemen that's our first
1800 let's go let's hope he doesn't
abort
[Music]
because we're too low-rated okay so
akarokan now there's many lines that i
recommend in the karoka but uh
let's play a very simple system
uh if we will which is e takes d5 the
exchange fire gun
and it's very important in this position
i taught this to charlie to go bishop d3
to stop his bishop from coming out to f5
now we are going to go c3 to build a
pawn chain
and here we need to develop the knight
from q1
knight f3 is actually inaccurate can
somebody tell me why
why is knight f3 a little bit inaccurate
what does it allow black to do very
conveniently
it allows black to go bishop g4 so
instead we're going to go knight e2
and the idea is that bishop g4 is no
longer a very
yeah he goes bishop g4 but now
we can actually get rid of the pin by
going queen to b3
you guys might be thinking well wait a
second why couldn't you do the same
thing with the knight on f3
well if you kind of visualize this and
i'll show this after the game
if knight f3 bishop g4 queen b3 he can
actually take the knight potentially
and ruin the pawn structure on the king
side which is quite bad because we're
probably going to castle to the king's
side
okay here we can just continue
developing we've unpinned ourselves
bishop defends the knight now he wants
to get his bishop to d6
what should we do about that what should
we do about that
bishop f4 simple he can actually still
go bishop d6 that's theory
but let's see if he knows this this is
okay no
knight d2 let's develop the knight
and he's probably gonna castle
and now let's tickle him always a good
idea
and uh now we need to improve thank you
squi for the prime we need to improve
our pieces
now if we take a look at our knights
right you guys see how these knights are
they're a little bit passive so first of
all we can take this knight and put it
on g3
and now now that he's castled by taking
on g6
we make a weakness in his pawn structure
if he wasn't castle the rook was on h8
i'd be reluctant to do that because the
rook would have access to that h file
but here
that h file is completely innocuous
let's improve the other knight
knight f3 simple very simple
straightforward chess
let's see what he does absolutely well
let's think about where we want to
position our rooks
now rook a1 would be a little bit mean
to the other rook
that other rook would end up on f1 and
it would be
a little bit bad so let's go rook f1 now
i don't know
where i'm going to put this other rook
yet but at least i give myself greater
freedom okay he attacks our queen we're
going to move it
and now we need to come up with a plan
now if you guys remember uh
we took on g6 which made him take with a
pawn
i introduced a concept to you guys in
the in the two games ago
called a hook a hoke is when there is a
pawn next to the king that is not on its
initial square
and we can use a hook in one of two ways
we can sacrifice a piece on it
or we can use our pawns to sort of hook
into that
hook and make further weaknesses on our
opponent's king side
now we're not going to go h5 yet that's
going to be a blunder
how are we going to set up the move h5
think about it this way right after h5
he's probably going to take
that's going to open a direct line
toward his king
so we want to go knight g5 because after
that happens we want to be poised
to deliver potential checkmate on h7
we'll have to distract the knight from
s6 but we can do that actually by
sacking it on h5
okay by the way we should also be
already considering
uh sacrifices like rook takes e6
although all of that is
quite dubious okay order of operations
order of operations our bishop is
hanging
let's take it and
what are we ready to do after he takes
what are we ready to do after he takes
push now queen f4 will be a very strong
move here let's see if he finds it i
i saw it don't worry and i have a really
strong response to it in mind
but i think it's the only way for him to
get a feasible position otherwise he
could get checkmated
now if g takes h5 can somebody remind me
of the move is is queen age seven there
is that checkmate and
if not and how do we make sure that it
will be checkmate a very simple
deflection of course it's not mate
because the knight guards the square but
we can deflect the knight
good job guys knight takes h5 and he
finds
now it's okay he's attacking the knight
which means that if he take the pawn he
takes our knight but we immediately need
to ask ourselves the next question
can we move this knight away with tempo
we don't need to panic we don't need to
sack
we need to ask ourselves whether we can
move this night away with tempo
can we move the night away with tempo be
can after the game i will explain
why sacrifices are bad in this position
now here's the thing uh and this is the
reason he's in trouble
because he has to move his queen but
look at the pawn on f7
do you guys see that that pawn is
overloaded it has to defend
both at e6 and now it has to defend g6
so black is going to lose a font uh not
it's actually not that simple but
basically that's what's going to happen
now you'll see why it's not that simple
if he correctly takes with the queen
but you got to be flexible right we
wanted to attack he defended against the
attack but in defending against the
attack
he created other weaknesses which we're
explaining this is what flexibility is
you've got to be able to stop on a dime
and completely change your strategy
at any moment based on what your
opponent does you can't have that one
track my oh
i wanted to attack okay what should we
do i kind of
gave away the move should we just take
the rook and give him the e file
is that something that we usually do no
okay one
we keep control of the e fun
knight f4 would blunder the night my
friend remember there is a queen on h6
so knight f4 would allow queen to except
for but also knight f4 would not be good
because
he could even take on e6 and then we
wouldn't have control of the e file
okay let's unpack this move he's
attacking our rook now option one would
be to trade on e8 twice that would be
fine because we're up a pawn
but um i don't really want to do that
you know i want to keep control of the
e-file how can we do that
how can we control yak we need to
malcolm on fire
now believe it or not this allows a very
interesting tactic but
let's see what what he does
now how should we go about thinking
about this position well this night on
h3
do you guys see any prospects for this
night potentially
where can this night potentially end up
so where do we want this knight and you
guys are already telling me the correct
idea um which is that the knight wants
to get go to g5
and we need to prepare that by playing
f4 we cannot go knight g5 because that
would blunder the knight
okay but first let's take on
on e4 i'm not blundering rook takes c6
because because
y
why is rook takes c6 not just winning a
rock because knight g5 checked
what should we do now
what should we do now guys
knight g5 of course that's our plan now
if he takes with the knight
then we can take the knight back but we
can immediately take the rook on yad and
win the game
so he has to move his king back
now after he moves his king to ga which
he will we have to be very careful and
find the accurate move because
if we take his knight then we drop our
rook on e6
okay and we can't do that so what we'll
need to do and rook takes ca gives up
the e file which i don't want
so we need to find a way to do two
things we need to get our queen away
from this pin
and preferably we need to defend the
rook on e6
so that we can play knight take c4 we
need to prepare this move in other words
queen a6 is possible but why why so
complicated
we can simply yes a good job queen g4
and that said his position collapses
the game is over he's lost
exactly simple chess
queen g4 we're threatening knight 64.
he's going to end up two pawns down
he could get smothered mated here it's
crushing
absolutely crushing and there are 1700
yeah rookie 8 queen b5 would also be
good
so okay now
bishop d3 i'll skip the opening because
it was quite simple again knight f3
here allows bishop g4 and this pin is a
little bit scarier
than this pin first of all we can play
f3 should the occasion
arise but also we can simply underpin
ourselves with quick queen v3
and and we don't need to worry about
this because we can simply take back
now bishop f4 knight d2 by the way
why can he go bishop d6 ah doesn't this
blunder upon could somebody tell me
doesn't this uh yes i beat andrew rook
b8 of course
and rook takes p2 restoring material
equality and cutting into black white
spawn structure
but he played bishop b7 key question
what happens if i do it anyway ask
yourself the sam shanklin question if
your opponent prevents an idea
you should spend at least 10-15 seconds
asking yourself
what happens if i do it anyway because
that can unlock your brain
and it can sort of help you eat into
those assumptions you make
which prevent you from finding certain
moves improving the knight improving the
knight
improving the rook and then asking
ourselves okay
what defects in black's position can we
take advantage of and we notice that
he's got a deficient king side what is
what does that mean
specifically he's got a hook on g6 how
do we use a hook we use it with our pawn
by advancing it first here then we
prepare h5 with knight you five
and then the key moment was here this is
the critical moment of the whole game
now what i want you guys to understand
is that an attack and i've talked about
this before is a function of two things
a successful attack
depends on two things being true number
one
uh is the fact it number one are the
presence of pieces
an attack can't happen unless there's a
certain amount of
a firepower of horsepower literally and
figuratively involved in the attack
number two weaknesses in your opponent's
king side
or or the area where your opponent's
king is if neither of those things are
true then an attack has very little
chance of succeeding
so if you think of a graph right
yeah okay so let me let's go to
microsoft paint let's go to microsoft
paint
it's time to make another painting
and uh okay x-axis and y-axis
and we're going to draw a sort of a an
asymptotic
graph sorry we don't want the fill here
we want
red and we want a brush
no we don't want a pencil though what i
want a thick brush
you want a thick brush there we go
so this graph
uh successful attacks
successful attack very very neat
handwriting too
successful attack i swear i have good
handwriting
now on the um x-axis here
uh is the sorry on the y-axis
jesus um
our oh my god this is embarrassing i'm
like
he drew a half pipe exactly um
f of x equals kappa yeah it's fine is
um number of
pieces
and on this axis is
weaknesses so
what this shows is that and
and let's call this um like let's do
this in terms of like
evaluation like eight whatever six
four two zero
i don't even this doesn't make any sense
at all what i'm trying to show
is that you have two defining main
defining factors in an attack number of
pieces
and the amount of weak squares so a
single queen can conduct a successful
attack
if your opponent's king is basically you
know
naked but you could also have a
situation where you have five pieces in
the attack
but your opponent's king is super well
defended the attack fails
you guys see what i'm saying i suppose
you could say there is
you know an attack is the function of
two variables
uh i guess you need some calculus here
number of pieces and weaknesses
anyways guys sorry back to the
back to the speed run so why is a move
like knight takes f7
bound to fail because
if we consider our function here that we
drew
we have one piece in the attack only one
does black have any real weaknesses on
his king side
like are there any specific targets
that you guys can identify here i know
but
i want to entertain you guys
queen protects h6 not really no targets
and black has one two three four pieces
in the defense
so you can rule this out without any
calculation minimal
minimal calculation you can rule this
stuff out that's what i'm trying to show
okay h takes g6 rookie 7 and again
the rook protects e6 um i know i'm i'm
kidding
so while this is an admirable attempt
that's why i was so dismissive about it
now queen takes g6 would have been
better because
after queen takes g6 f takes g6 okay
it's back to the chest please
can somebody explain to me why rook
takes c6 doesn't just win a pawn
for free
because b2 hangs question two
should we therefore play b3 is b3 a good
idea
no why not because it leaves c3 super
super weak and so black can counter
attack that pawn
what should we do how should we go about
defending b2
while making a move that is also
conducive to our
long-term pressure on the e6 pawn we
should go rookie 2
double rooks and involve this knight via
g5 now the fact of the matter is black
can protect the spawn but not for long
because once we put a knight on g5 this
pawn is going to be indefensible
so that's what we would have done and
black is still in very big trouble in
the cent game
so in my opinion after knight h3 black
is much worse
let's check our accuracy shall we i'm
just curious to see
what our accuracy was in this game i
think we actually played a nice game 94
yeah pretty is pretty solid
so you know this isn't bs i'm playing my
full strength here
any questions
not much longer i'm running out of gas i
did play 250 game match earlier against
andrew
his primary mistake was well first of
all bishop e7 is inaccurate
second of all i think that um
like somewhere here okay i think you
should have got knight takes d6
and like i don't know maybe like takes
and
94 defends i'm not sure actually uh but
at this point like we uh we're already
applying some pressure so
he made a series of very small
inaccuracies that kind of accumulated
um
would it have been better for him to not
trade his dark square bishop yeah
probably he could have kept it
he probably could have kept it but uh
already at this point he's in some
trouble why didn't we go 95 before he
won knight c4 because our queen is
hanging
so i suppose we technically can do this
but why trade so many pieces when we're
eventually trying to attack his king
right
okay barring any further questions let's
play one or two more and call it a night
okay well we've got
2 500 viewers which is awesome
if you could give this player one tube
to improve what would it be well i would
basically say
um yeah so study a little bit of this
karo khan theory
but um yeah anyways
so i won the match guys by a score of
approximately 110 to 90.
uh and uh the funny thing is i he's
higher rated than me now but um
i'll get back to 3 500. okay
let's continue
rakesh tiagi let's go e4 as we usually
do
and he goes with the modern which is g6
we simply develop our pieces and occupy
the center
and what move um i am tired but this is
just my
passion so what move should we play here
with white 26 bucks by flying chef thank
you so much man
should we go bishop e3 yes we should now
we can go f4 that's the austrian attack
but let's play bishop b3 why are we
playing bishop e3 because we are
remember when we have control of the
center we want to develop our pieces in
such a way
that we actually lend some support to
the center
you guys already know what the move is
here we've played it many times before
thank you so much man what should we do
we should not play queen d2 immediately
the problem with queen e2 immediately is
that he has the
nasty little move knight to g4 and so we
should go
f3 in order to prevent
the move knight g4
and and prepare queen t3 obviously we
are going to be castling long which is
the reason why f3 is acceptable
what is the purpose of queen d2 there
are two reasons we prepare castling
but there is a secondary reason and that
secondary reason we can literally just
play on the board right now
well we can start with h4 um we can
actually do that
but the top priority is to eliminate his
strongest piece
and he correctly strikes in the center
with c5
now what should we do here ladies and
gentlemen
since we are trading his bishop
we can now play the move what
which would be not good if we weren't
trading his bishop
because this move that we that i'm about
to play it would be a bad move
uh in theory because it actually opens
up his bishop
what am i talking about i'm talking
about the move d5
right we opened the diagonal for him but
because we trade his bishop
this move is fine but let's not take his
bishop yet
we can try to squeeze as much juice out
of this as possible what should we do
instead of taking
bishop a very typical attacking idea
a very typical attacking idea we need to
open up the h file because that's where
we're going to checkmate him
now edog suggests a4 to stop b5 but let
me tell you something
we don't even have to stop b5 we can go
straight for
his throat with h4
okay because we are very close to just
going h5 and opening up the h file and
checkmating him
watch what happens h5 he's probably
gonna go b4
okay now here's what we're going to do
we are going to now take his bishop on
g7
watch very carefully i will explain this
after the game
if he would have played bc kind of mull
over in your head what you would have
done but i'll show that
and guess what we do now what do you
guys think
should we move the night away
hint no
we can actually sack it sacrifice the
knight
we can take g6 hopefully he takes the
knight so i can demonstrate no he
doesn't he trusts us now we put the
queen on h6
and we've got a beautiful battery here
he's hanging by a single threat
okay now our knight is being attacked
we need to move the night we think about
where do we move the night well one good
idea is to maneuver this knight to a
nice little central square on e3
i think 92 would be worse because that
would block in the bishop
so let's get this knight around to e3
this guy is good he's defending well
now take a look at this knight and look
at it very carefully where should this
knight go
where should this knight go ultimately
it's a two-move maneuver
think about its destination don't think
about the next move
think about the destination g5
look at this beautiful square it's
exerting pressure on h7 and
it's attacking e6 so let's go knight h3
knight g5 or knight h3 knight f4
but knight g5 is even better than knight
f4 it's more stable there
let's go now he has to go in 85 correct
this knight is annoying can we
well first of all let's let's castle
let's complete our development let's not
commit to anything quite yet
and let's come up with a plan of action
now the plan that i propose
first of all we have not okay so he goes
not f7 we need to trade
which is not desirable but unfortunately
it's a necessity and it's okay
i have a an idea now
where should we put the bishop thank you
k for men
where should we put the bishop
we should put it on a weak square we
should put it on support because it
x-rays the queen of the king
you guys might be looking at this and
saying well wait a second his pawn's on
d6 what are you talking about
this bishop looks stupid remember
potential energy kinetic and potential
energy this bishop has a ton of
potential energy
if this diagonal opens up and we can
actually make that happen
eventually by playing e5 now first of
all
he wants to go queen up for potentially
a trade queens
although that's actually not a threat as
i'll show you guys but
um let's first of all
uh let's try to uh triple pieces on the
h let's go rook h4
then double on the h file and then we'll
potentially have a triple situation on
the h file
okay
now let's see what he does
now secondary idea is for us to go f4
and d5 as i mentioned earlier
we want to open up this um
this tag i'm actually going to go hmm
this guy is good i'm actually going to
go e5 yeah let's go e5
no this guy is playing extremely well
and i'm cutting it close on the clock so
let me focus for a second we're still
doing fine
i just i'm going to explain a couple of
things after the game
let's go d6 exposing his king
and now we're going to go knight well
actually no let me think
yeah knight you four
let me focus for a second guys
yeah this guy is surprising me with his
play
quite a bit actually
but we'll be fine
don't try this at home though knight d7
there's a p6 check okay
knight f8 we're up a piece we attacking
the knight and we want to go d7 and
promote the fun
don't worry everything is under control
everything is under perfect control
yeah this guy is good um but um you know
i'll explain the last couple of moves in
a moment okay so
yeah i can win this even with 10 seconds
don't worry
trust me i've been doing this for a very
long time
so why why was rook takes f4 bad idea
here guys
why why is rook takes a 4 of that idea
here
somebody tell me i won't make a move
until somebody tells me
knight e2 yeah
now watch
you see it's all going to be fine
now that was a very tricky game this guy
was good it was very very good
now let's unpack some of these moments
first and foremost
a lot of people wonder why f3 is better
than h3
could somebody explain to me why when
you're trying to prepare queen d2 and
stopping knight g4 what additional
benefit
does f3 have over h3
what additional benefit does this move
have over this move compare them sorry
thank you so much let's get some hype
going for the prime
i think we're over 3500 supporting the
center
right the more things you get done with
the move the better
so this supports the center now
so boom boom we trade the bishops we go
d5 to close up the center
we could have gone a4 here to stop b5
maybe i should have
because he kind of got a lot of counter
play now first of all
can somebody tell me what happens after
knight takes h5 the board might be
frozen yes sorry
sorry sorry sorry
can somebody tell me what happens
after knight takes h5 here
did somebody tell me what happens after
knight takes h5
guys it's unfrozen please rook takes h5
queen g5 and this is as old as time and
queen takes g7 checkmate is unstoppable
now if he tries to play bc
preemptively then we go queen to h6
right the queen occupies the square just
vacated by the bishop and now we have a
huge attack
this is not worrisome because of rook to
b1
okay now here what would have happened
if b takes e3 some really interesting
complications arise because of this
could somebody tell me the next move
in h6 now if king h8 then we go g74
the king of the rook so king g8 is
forced
white to play trick question do not make
the tempting move
this is not checkmate this is not easy
to win but i believe it is winning
we do not want to go g takes h7 check
because the king is going to use this
pawn as an umbrella and it's going to be
perfectly safe
so we want to actually go g7 and now we
have this position
now we need to think logically what does
that mean
that means that the queen wants to
deliver checkmate on h7 but it cannot
because there's a knight on f6 so the
immediate next question has to be
two questions number one can i get rid
of this knight
number two can i apply additional
pressure on the
h7 square now be very careful about how
you go about doing that
right f4 e5 is not correct
because the e5 square is defended very
well by the other knight
but here's what we can try to do first
of all this is what i would have done
we can bring the knight to g5 and use
that knight to capture h7
bishop d3 would be another very sneaky
idea but he could put his knight on e5
to stop you from going e5 knight h3
knight g5 is unstoppable
black simply i think has no way to stop
nitro5
although maybe it's not that simple okay
so bishop d3 uh he has 95
right does that make sense you can't go
e5
now g4 is possible but here's the
problem guys
with g4 g5 the problem is that let's
make a random move
even if you do this and you play g takes
f6
black's other knight replaces the first
one so i get it you want a piece
you're not going into this for a piece
you're going to this for checkmate
and so here you you have the same
problem over again
right you don't just want to get rid of
the knight you want to get rid of the
knight
and and the other night as well you want
to do it in a way that doesn't allow
a block to get the other knight to f6
okay
now if you go bishop d395 f4 then knight
takes d3 check
and uh you get a problem which is that
if e5
well now black can go bishop to f5 and
use the bishop to defend the pawn so
bad stuff just kind of happens here
so um yeah now you can do it jose but
we've made random moves for black black
is not going to make random moves trust
me
black is going to play cb and he's going
to go queen a5 and queen takes a2 you
have like one move to do something so
that's why i think knight h3 is super
important
you have to act with a sense of urgency
all right so here we got the knight
around to a good square
then we got the other knight to a good
square
then we went bishop c4 rook h4 to stop
queen f4
he tripled we went up for e5 opening up
the bishop and now i actually had a
beautiful move knight g4 i just checked
is kind of inaccurate
we had to move f5 just crunching through
his position he cannot take because of
the pin
and he cannot take the other way because
the knight falls
instead i went knight g4 in order to get
my knight to e5 white is still better
here
and the pressure is immense even though
we're in an end game and even though i'm
up
a couple of pawn i'm down a couple puns
it doesn't matter because look at how
active my pieces are
and guess what piece wins the game it's
the bishop the bishop that looked
terrible
wins the game because it has so much
potential energy
okay didn't we have 96 for a fork before
at which point i'm not sure when you're
referring to well 96 here
remember his bishop can now take the
knight simply
okay so um i actually realized something
and i made a mistake which is that queen
of four is not actually a threat
why can somebody tell me why this is not
actually a threat
rook takes h5 exactly very good and the
rook simultaneously defends our queen
boom boom and the game is off
okay does 250 thank you so much
does this make sense very good any
questions
last speedrun game
yeah okay last game
we are over 1700
am i eating okay oh yes
1800 again here we go you see guys we're
playing good people but
it's not okay he aborted
i guess we'll go again 1712 exactly the
same rating from russia
of course oh then you take the queen by
the way okay so french
uh now in the french i'm gonna go knight
to c3 which is the main line
he takes that's what andrew tang plays
and he goes knight f6 we take the knight
now we develop very naturally here
knight to f3 white is better in this
line
and now we have a very tricky move d3
let's see oh and he missed it we can win
the game on the spot
with what move ladies and gentlemen drum
roll please
that's why you don't bring your queen
out before every other piece
that's exactly why you don't bring your
queen out in the opening that's why that
piece of advice exists
mr queen mrs queen where do you go
miss ms uh my lady where where are you
gonna go
my lady uh here
oh wait a second i think there's a
knight guarding that's here oh wait no
huh oh queen can't be trapped on move
eight can it
that's it game over he had to play h6
here that's theory
theory is the move h6 stopping bishop g5
okay he's probably fuming right now
yeah this is actually very typical so
okay not bad uh i was like 160
okay he resigned so perfect time now for
the last speedrun game
okay b y cp let's play another sicilian
and he plays the wing gambit so the wind
gambit is
something that sicilian players often
fear
the idea of the wing game but okay
bishop c4 is bad
the move is a3 there now
um how should we go about playing this
position
well what do you guys think we should do
yeah we should develop but how should we
develop
we have a pretty cool idea here which is
to go knight f6
and this invites e5 but we have a very
sexy move here can somebody find it
a very sexy response and this response
always exists when there is a bishop on
c4
boom goes the dynamite d5 you guys might
look at them and say
wait a second he can go bishop b5 check
he probably is going to do that in like
the next five seconds
okay no he took but by the way in that
event of that we could have gone bishop
to d7
counter-attacking his bishop and if he
takes we play knight f takes d7
moving that same knight which is being
attacked to take back the bishop
here he's just in huge trouble look at
our monster pawns
we're up upon he's got nothing developed
i mean this is just
horrible for white f takes e7 we're
going to take back with the bishop
prioritizing our development over a
meaningless check
okay well
well actually there's a couple things we
could do right he wants to take this
so what do you guys think that we should
do can we maybe defend
this pawn and make a development move at
the same time
it looks a little bit awkward but it's a
really strong move malcolm tucker you
are on fire my friend
bishop e6 bishop b6
defending upon and developing our bishop
now you guys might be looking at this
and saying
but wait this new bishop b6 you usually
tell me not to play it
because it obstructs the development of
this bishop but
this is an exception because obviously
he's going to have to do something with
the spawn
and that's going to solve for us the
problem of this bishop he decides to
simply give that pawn away which opens
up our bishop look how beautifully we've
developed our pieces
curly johnny thank you for the three
months glad to hear that my friend
glad to hear that okay c3
well we can take but let's go a5 to keep
our beautiful pawn mass
alive here and then we're going to
complete our development
and castle and we're going to win easily
his bishop is also completely
stuck because of this nice little pawn
mass that we've got
you're watching from san fran great okay
knight c6 stopping knight d4 also
bishop c5 getting the bishop on the most
active square these moves i'm not really
explaining because they're simple
and
okay so this is winning
yeah this is interesting no the people
are uneven i mean we're in a castle
and let's see if i can play some regular
bullet after that to finish
no actually there's nobody online
maybe some blitz regular blitz i'm not
that sleepy for some reason i don't know
why
like i'm tired but i feel like going i'm
feeling pumped for the match
okay so let's unpack
the situation have a way to trade queens
here
and um the simplest thing here would be
to trade queens because we're up several
pawns and we've got everything developed
and uh i want to show you guys how to
win in an end game
how can we trade queens there's two
possible moves here
mr gambini are you on drugs drugs no i
don't take drugs queen d5 or queen d3 is
exactly right
yeah i'm on adrenaline right now
i am high on life as they say
queen d3 is correct and um
you know we're up two puns it makes
sense to trade queens and then we're
gonna get a beautiful pawn on d3
yeah queen d5 was just as good both
moves were perfectly fine
uh they were alternatives all roads lead
to rome here
okay so he takes it we're going to take
and hopefully now i can show you guys
end game technique so he activates his
knight
so um how should we go about
um playing this position what should we
do
well first of all we need to identify
uh where the sort of
pressure points are right what's going
on here what is the battle revolving
around
you guys see right that the rooks are in
a standoff
so does it make sense that if we can
gain control of the
of the a file then that would signify
progress toward eventually infiltrating
does that part make sense okay
now um then we ask ourselves the next
question right which is how do we get
control of the a file and the idea of
knight before knight c2 comes to mind
okay knight before knight c2 would
dislodge his rook from a1
and it would give us control of the a
file but there is a problem
and here's the problem if we go night
before
he can beat us to the punch with what
move
how can he beat us to the punch if we go
night before
he can go knight c7 first so here's what
we're going to do we're going to go
bishop b6
dropping back the bishop and preparing
to go night before knight c2
prophylactic move looks mysterious but
hopefully i've guided you guys
through each sort of step of my thinking
process here
knight d6 okay that's okay he attacks
our pawn
on b7 but this is a completely innocuous
move
for many different reasons and i'm
actually going to do something that
looks
crazy i'm going to sacrifice this pawn
uh why am i doing that because i believe
that the a file is
so important that it's worth sacrificing
a pawn over it
because once we get a rook to the second
rank and this speaks to perhaps the most
important he doesn't even take it
see how this worked peace activity in
the end game is incredibly important
sometimes even more important than
material okay you want to make sure your
pieces are active
all right so now we want to centralize
our bishop but first we want to
reap the rewards of what we just did so
let's go rook a2
okay i did not blunder that the knight
defends the bishop the bishop is what we
call a type 2 undefended piece
what can we do
beautiful guys beautiful bishop c4
that's it the game is over he's going to
lose his knight
and everything is going to collapse and
this is a direct product of us getting
the rook to a2 we won the battle over
the a file
and therefore we won the game actually
oh no we didn't not yet
ah just kidding okay we don't need to
attack the bishop
his knight is permanently pinned he has
no way to save it
he thought he could catch me like that
he is wrong boom
and we are up in exchange and the rest
is very simple let's bring the bishop
back to
c4 let's now identify the weaknesses in
his position and work toward attacking
them
the d4 pawn is the weakness that we can
attack
our past pawn and we can take it now as
i've explained many times how do you win
an end game like this in the most
efficient way
you identify where the past pawn is and
you push it
but here he just gives us a free knight
now we couldn't have taken it
immediately because
bishop takes d4 and he resigns so
um very simple d5 was the key move
if bishop b5 checked we would have gone
bishop d7
takes takes then e6 we would be up a
pawn with a beautiful pawn chain
so this was all very straightforward
very straightforward queen d5 here would
be perfectly good as well
they would be alternatives although it's
a little bit less forcing maybe he can
drop his queen back here
but queen d3 is quite forcing because it
also attacks the knight right
and here the move bishop e6 i want you
guys to pay attention to this move
right step by step logic where is the
battle revolving around
well the a file right that's the only
standoff that we have
we want to gain control of the eiffel
how do we do that by dislodging his rook
how do we dislodge his rook till the
only possible ways to get the knight to
c2
okay what's what's stopping us well he
can do the exact same thing from his end
and gain control of the a file
so can we stop knight c7 first and then
go knight before knight c2
that's exactly what we did rook a2
see that's how we want the game
[Music]
you